if you're watching the nintendo direct
or nintendo main events yesterday
morning you probably saw a trailer that
involved some idol singers some flying
pegasi and a lot of other dramatic shots
but we're taking a look at that game
today it's called sharp Fe and here to
talk to me about it Ryan and Ally from
Nintendo and Takata song from Atlas
welcome everybody glad to have you guys
here Ali's back she's been a regular on
this day but Ryan Takata son thank you
so much for coming up here they all
thought I might stop there I think
either one that's coitus my thanks for
thanks for fighting us excellent now we
are gonna we've got a demo in progress
right now but to get the title of the
game was originally shin megami tensei
cross fire emblem is that correct aight
aight any consolation not scatter the
wall thai drama on whom 900g mettawa smt
x80 tied to this toggle through a touch
police car so lazy nano bit of a Corrino
tokyo amada Korra Bravo shimasu ka hana
show on nintendo's ando sabah peloton Oh
day oh Bakari escano capaz de parte mia
dosta so when we actually announced that
title for everybody that many years ago
um that was just after we decided with
Nintendo to make the collaboration and
we had that title in place just to show
people in a really understandable way
that that collaboration was going to
take place so we've got the
collaboration in place and it's going to
be presumably combining characters
elements from those different games but
can you give us just an overview of
basically what kind of game it is for
the player when they sort of pick up the
game and play it and talk winnable game
we need to eat a new system on the scale
mode only on Amazon you taking a dawning
on a know gaming in 90 moscato let's
make the house Oh no ha pasado cuando su
JRPG knee hi IM bremen oh so Loretta
non-condensing kino are digas nada mas
aqui como eres Cubano hiya embryonic at
a demo at o d'azur annika tenemos
oversee ma seater a tomar a steady yo
Rita no see so you gave me nothing so
when the player picks us up they'll know
that they can know that it's an RPG that
Atlas is known for making so as you said
before we've introduced elements of the
fire boom series and the shin megami
tensei sears into this game but one
thing that we want to stress as the fact
that
as a game that's totally new that's
being made for people who are completely
new to the game and new to the series
and it had well despite that it has
elements that people will pick up who
are firemen fans who are shipping on me
tense a series fans and they'll say oh I
know that that's from somewhere I've
seen that before something like that so
touch points for both of those fans but
an RPG that anyone familiar with Atlas
RPGs can come right into and enjoy a new
coat oh I've told us no my RPG no suki
na kappa gamma saguni cool walk on walk
RTS co-called play the kitty only
another people of this name so listen a
high yeah that's that about sums it up
alright well we just saw a a scene of a
singer floating in the sky giving a
wonderful performance the sort of the
animation they're very lively very
detailed and now we're moving into sort
of a conversation in the gameplay can
you set the stage for where we are in
the game right now and toast or do you
know Iman I got a machine on disk adamo
80 so no hiking sweetie to cocoa said
tomato la con el estado porygon o0oi no
tsubasa know you care act an indiscreet
amo con ojos ah so no gano Cairo Meza so
T chica carenado di cecina even Doris
Day a non-con oh yeah so no gym uno de
esquina a no a TI so dire qu'il ya know
Laveau meet a a no soy una con joakim
optimo tano dec 08 a given anata no
kokoro ni mucho gamemode karateka energy
me camera image a text up give away so
what's happening right here is the
character with the blue hair that you're
seeing on the screen is the female
protagonist named Tsubasa and she wants
to become a singer what's also known as
an idol in Japan and she's at this live
event of the singer named kittiya who
was dancing in the video that you saw
the cutscene that you saw before and she
now was so moved by the performance
you'll see that she's holding a glowing
ball of energy in her hand but that
represents how much she was moved that
kind of energy that sprung forth in her
and it renewed her desire to become a
singer excellent so well it's fabulous
it's not just a quick you know easy road
to the top of course in the music
industry in any world have you been
there is fraught I'm just really
inferring this from the facts [ __ ] boy
portals are appearing all around the
world seems like it might be slight
obser
right right what kind of obstacles are
we dealing with here in the RPG sort of
what's the antagonist force at 0 e mono
kiku mono nan desu kedo no no no hi I'm
no corrupt attached eva kaam kiya no se
que Cara no a la de da no hijo de puta
not even de cerca a no-sew nunica mi
police kono sekai oh sono koe bostero te
amo EDC a nose Kuramoto khanomi tiny soo
single jacaro cast a credo 10 muy bien
SI gamma por ESO es una Sydney ho ho
tacoma SE qayamat anne edano hoga same
adicta david zotos so it's actually on
the antagonist in this game are similar
to the Fire Emblem characters that
you'll see two they're known as mirages
and their visitors from another mirror
dimension and they'll show up in there
there are evil mirages there are good
mirages the evil mirages like this
character that you're seeing on the
screen are there to destroy the world
and their motives are not clear yet but
they're also good mirages like you'll
see later that kromm from firing
awakening or Sita from the first fire
emblem game will also show up and help
out so yeah look forward to how that
plays out we got a mild spoon from the
end of the couch when prom was mentioned
is my bread I yeah but oh my my oh give
their cooters so I'm during awakening
you know you get attached to these
characters and then you sort of invest
yourself in them and their fates and
sometimes their romantic fates is that
sort of romance option that kind of
pairing up of different characters in
the game very happy oh no kakera no I
don't know day night you know re mosca
solely on o menos story guy para naka de
80 kaku sorry Ximena kimitachi que un
des que no mo ano Harry ragazzo no sato
state emma xing a no astro hinari tiger
optimo atari jarritos urinary tract amo
esta Rima Matassa Chiodo no tsubasa
meetin i Doan el texto me vino de carros
en casa photos recodo de carreras de con
mi vida guerra matana story gah ademas
Soriano shoot me know Selita bitoni Nene
a sober cadres so I don't want to touch
on the love situation specifically
however what I can say is that it
the main storyline there are also side
story lines reach of the characters that
you encounter in your journey and
basically each of these characters has
goals you know some one of the
characters Tsubasa wants to be a singer
another one of the characters Toma wants
to be an action star and in helping them
fulfill their dreams their connections
between the characters will change and
something might happen so all right
excellent now before we sort of wrap up
the demo can we talk a little bit about
how you deal with a bad mirage you know
it comes at you it's trying to disrupt
you is there combat do you just write
scathing like reviews online about that
Mirage you downvote them that's what I
did that's our power but video games
allow us to dream greater a tomar una
mom taking a miracle what we need oh you
through Nicole a tidy Sheamus cono cono
Snow Patrol's Lucas hora termina todo
deco are we Giovanni all right dodo you
from the early master hey des neige yo
Danny Imam et al apto dark road on
Johnny shimbun encanto de gaurav re no
day pasolini key biscuit a Suharto Pato
rabota radios so you see you've seen
right now or right now we're going on to
a different time right now but what you
saw before on the screen was there was
an enemy Mirage showing up on the
dungeon map and you enter into combat
itself by either running into the enemy
or doing a slash function with your
sword which is something that fans of
the ship megami tensei series will see
and be like oh I've seen that before so
high legends Cup yeah it's like you
cannot own taken up so when we go into a
battle i think sarah if we're going into
a battle yeah we're going to the boss
battle okay in the next boss battle
he'll continue that so that it's easy
for everybody understand at home alright
I think we'll have just time to take a
quick glimpse at the boss battle in
action maybe we can take a look at this
island many muscle did Joab they are
well that's I mean that's the thing that
the shin megami tensei series certainly
brings to the table style for miles was
that a technical term you guys use in
the studio at those Shin Megami Tensei
series nan desu kedo demo at Oggo nico
biscay must I resuna kanji got a
mosquito any other levels he says thanks
for that I know
seguro little sedan and a scale oconee
mo anos to take assassinate oh no oh no
oh yeah lacto motto Rastadt oh
sacramento todo que comida as we get
owned a dummy Danny study a traffic in a
consequence so you saw before that Sita
was on the screen and she is the Pegasus
Knight reprimand one and she's
represented in this game very
differently from how fans for the fire
fireman one remember her and we actually
kind of gave it that as you said Atlas
style for miles uh for the further
representation in this game excellent so
now we're seeing the boss I'm sorry to
cut this on please go again David Bowie
got on they go to pollute the Mariana
what the way I don't we do it so in the
same way this is Gangrel the bosses are
fighting right now who is also the last
or sorry don't wanna spoil that who's
also a character from off the farm em
series and his head will take off and
spin around a blade shopper of death and
that's something else that we also kind
of gave her at whisper up debt Atlas
tastes plato's death giant fire tornado
and high heels stop to the head all
moves you can expect to see in battle in
sharp Fe can you guys give us an idea of
when this is gonna be releasing and what
platforms will be able to see it on but
it's soooo hot soup i started a new
honda nice n jus gon end a negative
america line in destin atacama so this
is going to be available on the wii u
and in japan japanese gamers can look
forward to this 2015 but for American
gamers we'd like to get this out in 2016
for them thank you so much Ryan Ally to
caucus on for coming off on coming on
and showing off sharp Fe alright folks
here at the game spot live stage we are
coming back shortly with a look at
destiny's biggest new expansion outside
the season pass zone it's the taken King
coming up next